[Music]
hello everyone I'm Grand Master Dennis
Porsche and we are here to take a look
how to prepare like a pro
now this time we are going to discuss a
legendary player's secret weapon and
that's Alexi Shiro now if you do not
know Alexis Europe you've been missing
out has been one of the top players in
the 90s and the 2000s the opening that
we're going to actually look at is the
French and here he goes for Pawn E4 to
E5 now there of course are plenty of
options in fact played in the World
Championship matches like saying id2 or
Knight C3 like in the tall butvinik
match or Knight D2 which was the carpo
of course noi match and a recent dinapol
niachi dingleren
but instead Alexia shirov's favorite is
E4 E5 the whole point being that a
bishop on C8 is actually walled up and
it cannot really Escape without any
concessions but let's stick to the topic
here Alex Fisher wasn't just a top 10
player I like to say shirov was also the
one who actually beat Vladimir kramneck
was slated to play a world championship
match against none other than Gary
Kasparov but for one reason or another
did not actually get to play that match
now even though that didn't happen he
still made it to knockout world
championship finals and often lost
narrowly to Future Champions such as
Vichy Anand and talking about future
Champions and recent ones we are having
a grand chess Tour event in Bucharest in
two days so on Saturday 7 A.M in the
morning Yasser is going to welcome you
with his morning coffee so if that is
something you're interested to
definitely make sure you're ready you
have YouTube Ready
and the show will promptly go on live
with Rapport dinglieren Bogdan mvl
ferrugia and many many others so if
you're interested in that you should not
miss that one it's going to be classical
so it's not going to be super fast paced
but it's gonna be high quality as you
may have seen in the world championship
match
but back to our slated topic of the day
meaning preparing like Alexi shirov so
black goes and tries to undermine the
center that is sort of one of the
downside of pushing the E Pawn you do
have to defend the center that you just
claimed come on to C3 Knight C6 Knight
F3 Bishop D7 now plenty of moves here
there is moves such as A3 and Bishop E2
we are going to take a look at many of
these options actually just two of those
here share of event for Bishop E2 but
fret not these actually
kind of transposed to each other so
they're fairly similar and very close in
topic 97 okay so here is a very
important moment to stop we must Wonder
a what is our opponent planning to do B
how we can strengthen the structure that
we have
so one of the best ways of understanding
and opening that you're learning is to
actually come up with ideas of your own
that you think is worthy of the position
something that you'd consider personally
to play it yourself
now I already gave you the hint that it
has to be somewhat of a strengthening
move otherwise this whole Center that we
have may collapse
already black is putting some pressure
on the D4 Square
now of course we don't have to panic
already we've got these guys defending
the D4 Pawn but soon ER or later it may
actually reach a critical point
so chat and everyone here your job right
now will be to try to figure out a move
that you'd consider to play here
and don't necessarily worry about it if
you don't quite get the move that sure
will play eventually it's all about
realizing if you got the feel or you
feel comfortable with the position
yourself
foreign
how can we bolster bolster that pawn on
D4
Bishop E3 okay very natural move
okay
Chad actually considers Knight to A3
which does look very weird however
that's not the end destination
the night is heading towards C2
and then from there defend the D4 Palm
and once you sort of realize these are
like the two main options so that's
correct
there's actually a third one but it's
somewhat less popular and also is not
the engine's favorite not that
necessarily matters
so you got these two options
and the way you sort of realize which
one might be better is if you look at
the possible options for your opponent
so you look at it you say Okay I want to
get the bishop or I want to get the
Knight out you may want to wonder how
you can go after the d-pawn as black
like how can black put even more
pressure on The Possession
Knight F5
so in light of Knight F5
which one would be the preferred method
of defenses this or this one
and a3y
exactly
so Bishop E3 is by no means necessarily
bad but it does leave your Bishop to be
attacked
so that is actually the reason it makes
sense to actually spend a little bit of
time before you make a choice
because you may have not considered your
opponent's ideas
and here in ia3 is really good now one
thing that's pretty important in this
line that shirov plays now Knight E3
here wouldn't be as great because black
could capture capture and take the
Knight
but as the night is on E7 it
uncomfortably blocks this diagonal for
the bishop so after the trade of Pawns
you actually don't have a chance to snip
that Knight
Knight F5 Knight C2
okay so we did a little bit of work for
the black side but let's do a little bit
more how can we how can they actually
amp up even more pressure on the d-pawn
between B6
simple as that just amping up the
pressure
okay so this is the moment we have to
sort of wonder
what we could play here as white
it kind of uh depends on our comfort
level are we happy with this pressure
and it's a it's no biggie we are going
to actually fend off this one or if we
say well that's too much pressure we
don't really want to deal with it and
that actually gives us different options
if we kind of compare or kind of decide
what we prefer and what's our taste in
chess
he does take on E3 we get a semi yeah
but you do give up the bishop so yes you
get some positives there my gargle but
also there's a negative that she lost
the bishop there
so and all of this we are in the opening
so
you can't play many many moves but that
does not necessarily mean they're bad
but there could be disadvantages that
other other moves won't have
very comfortable with this pressure
okay
is that a sign of discomfort I mean just
not liking the attack or just G4 anyways
okay it's just like in G4 okay I can't
argue with that I'm a big fan of G4 too
go ahead what is your thought
You're Gonna Cancel okay
so
if you know Alexa shirov
I don't think it's a big question which
movie chose
um and if you're familiar with him as a
player
a little bit
so what is your guess
you know it's 50 50. you can't really go
terribly wrong
Vinnie Castle did he go G4
so shirov is Mr fire on the board
meaning he loves complications so
obviously he does go G4
now castling is fine as well there's
nothing wrong with that
but cheer of just like to see everything
get complicated and you'll see it in
this game as well
G4 is a move that actually has a lot of
weight on it so it's either really good
or it's really really not good because
you are sort of moving a Pawn on this
side of the board however it's a closed
position so compare it to a sicilian or
even the Spanish I mean some forms of
like the open Spanish there you're more
likely to get punished for a palm push
in front of your king but this is a
closed position it's pretty rigid in the
middle so it'll take some time for that
to explode
so even though you made this move it's
very difficult to get to and even get
difficult to get to the king so Knight
E7 and now he castles H5 so now we
really have to sort of realize and kind
of decide how we're going to respond to
this move of Pawn H7 to H5
H3
okay
so do you consider any other moves apart
from HD and that goes to everyone over
here and then chat too
foreign
so there's some lucky people who have
the right feel like the intuition for
the game but sometimes they're
positioned at some familiar so I think
it's a better way of looking at chess if
you sort of make a reason why other
moves wouldn't fit your bill or would be
something that you wouldn't prefer like
give a reason
if you do if you don't you don't
any other moves that we could consider
which movie you're thinking about
okay so reason reason with me like if I
pushed upon what's wrong with that
mm-hmm
very good so G5 would just not make any
sense because the Knight goes back and
this extra space is meaningless because
they can just lock it all up and we
achieve nothing
now even though it never got played Pawn
captures are often an idea especially if
the pawn could be defended because yes
then I may go back but in you know
there was a price and the price was the
pawn
yeah H3 is the best because you keep
this position going and you don't really
let the Knight back in
and this is actually fairly typical The
Rook buy-in itself isn't going to
Checkmate you if the queen was on d8
maybe they could try to attack you but
not here
so takes takes F6
Bishop D3 activating the bishop long
castles
and this is sort of the position where
you sort of have to remember the basic
ideas about Chess
so
opposite side castling
what does the big
book write about that
foreign
opposite side casting does not mean that
any of the sides are worse has nothing
to do with the evaluation of the
position like that
it definitely just means sharp but there
is a strategical element that is really
important to know
what the opposite side castling entails
and that is
yeah easy to attack but why
easier much easier to attack
but what is the reason for that
there is a reason for that and actually
shirov uses it in this game
well it's good because you can rule and
give away Pawns in front of your
opponent's king
if your Castle on the same side
it's difficult because you might get
checkmated quicker you can't just throw
pawns I mean we're kind of going against
that a little bit but not really we're
not going further than that
so the whole point of this I'm ready
just to give up a pawn if needed
for the fact that I just want to open up
files on the CNB files
possible
so Knight takes so here look from Valley
who used to be one of the best Dutch
players trust to Muddy Waters
but of course it's a gift that we are
not going to refuse
on captures
can't quite take this
because their screen takes D4
but uh shirov plays a cool calm and
collected move
that is kind of nice so let's try to
find that one this is typical shirov
not panicking at all
Bishop here
very logical
but probably just take
oh that's it's a little
a little aggressive I go King B8
so here actually Shiro realized huh
my opponent is a little bit stuck the
King on seat is not ideally placed right
not at all so your goal would be to make
it stick there so it can't run away
so it comes up with this very weird
looking move of Queenie too
but queenie2 sort of um
actually forces
black to consider captures right
but then we'd have a very very strong
move what would that be
yes so if it takes we have this idea and
the king is stuck and sometimes it's not
as much important to be material up as
it is to make sure your opponent's king
is in an absolute Target now if you go
on id2 there is Pawn to E4 so you lose
the piece anyways eventually
so queenie2 is sort of setting up a
situation where you could take advantage
of that
in Black indeed pushed the pawn
but I didn't stop Shiro from going
Bishop F4 and the idea being that the
king is still stuck
now G6 and again this is sort of those
moments where you sort of have to wonder
a little bit about the importance of
pieces you got to remember which is the
key piece and remember to hold on to it
and the key piece is
the G the bishop on F4 that that is the
dark squared Bishop because it just
keeps this King locked the rest it it
doesn't really matter if they take it
they take it so check
here
Bishop D6
now even though we're kind of happy with
the way Shiro of Alexis shirov mobilized
his pieces you do have to you know
eventually go for the attack otherwise
you're not going to win this game
well that's aggressive but you're again
giving up material what is your
follow-up if I capture
just capture
so you can be aggressive without giving
away your pieces it's better to give
away your opponent's pieces
Bishop B5 that that's a looker it's a
good look and move
but why not just go after
with the pawn right simple as that
just go after the bishop it's pinned
just win it takes half takes EF
they take the bishop but so with every
position things shift so excuse me that
I go back a little bit yes but this
bishop really mattered until we could
set up threats afterwards we don't care
foreign
E6
check
okay
we need six if I move my king
so you always have to wonder about your
opponent's threats first
that's the key
okay so Queen F2 what if I bring my
knight to E5
with the idea really that I want to
capture the bishop
if you go take here well your knight is
hanging
and really what chess is about is you
put one plus one together
we looked at this
look at this
so basically we're molding all those
ideas together and make sure the Knight
doesn't go to E5 because we just capture
it and even though this looks scary and
you know most of the time you'd love to
choose Queen to F2 just to blockade
everything off but it does give this
Knight E5 as an option
so Queen C7 you're not gonna blunder
Maiden one because if we take this here
B takes takes Queen takes and the game
is practically over
because there's a double attack and we
win
so this is actually the typical way of
playing this um
Advanced variation
you may actually take some risks
but if you fan of the attack as we did
earlier so somewhere around here
you may actually get like a free attack
on the other side so obviously there
were plenty of threats and counter
threats right so it's not like white
goes plays and wins
but it is complicated variations where
both sides will have some chances and
then share of wins
so let's see another game where we see
this line in fact it's one of a
different version of this variation here
here Queen B6 so we've seen this one
with Knight E7 but we're not now going
to take a look at Queen B6
A3 and this is a different method we
talked about Bishop E2 but the
difference is the Knight is not on E7
they go Knight to H6
B4
captures and now in chess in reality
there's always like a hierarchy of moves
in this case we have this momentum of
deciding where we want to capture first
and we want to capture the Knight
because it rules the structure
however it also has a downside what do
you guys think what could be a potential
downside in this position for us
yeah our dark squared is completely weak
we don't really have that Defender
anymore and that's actually one of the
reasons Bishop to E3 and that nitrate
isn't as popular because the dark
squares again become kind of loose
okay but what's the upside though
because there definitely is an upside to
this trade
the bishop of course is still locked in
on C8 but that's just one of those
things
what other upside we have
and I'm really talking about strategic
upsides here
but our pawns are all on dark squares in
fact that's the way it's supposed to be
that's the names of ichian way you're
trying you get rid of your own bad own
bishop and then you wall up your
opponent's bishop and you're Walling up
this bishop
that is the whole point
so they're actually not just one but two
bad Bishops
but okay what is the other strategic
element that is in White's favor it's
kind of self-explanatory
so try try to think about it yeah
the pawn structure yeah but that's not
just the double Pawn but of course one
of those things
it's not the most important part of the
board that's what I'm trying to say here
the important part of the board is
always the important part of the board
which is
the center
who owns the center we do
we've got the center they don't and in
fact now this is not really talked about
as much but we also cross the
demarcation line
um and what that does is that often
black cannot put uh
pieces on D6 and F6 which are the most
active squares that they could go to on
their turf
but that's impossible because sort of we
encroached in their area
and second but not last we also got a
little bit of extra space on the other
side now it's not as great in the middle
because that's even better because we
moved into opponent territory but here
we are close enough we already own our
side of the space
and black really doesn't have anyone
there
okay so Bishop D7 Rook A2 and this move
is a very creative idea by Alexei shirov
he's going there to overprotect the D4
Pawn here
G3 Rook G4 and this is something called
the tabiya position
um meaning something that often recurs
because it's one of those critical
positions that you get almost by force
or at least something that both sides
kind of find critical
so Rook D2 now Knight D2 is a natural
move but you're sort of ignoring your
opponent's main idea which is to take
the palm the reason in the first place
why you went to A2 is so you'll be able
to defend this
so now
Wong decides to take on B4 says well I'm
going to get two Pawns
and I'm gonna take your Rook
so again I'm gonna ask the same thing
that we did in the first game what does
our hunch say what should be a move
considered here as white you know and
also you know trade tread carefully here
because black may actually attack you if
you're a little bit uh too aggro and not
cautious enough
Bishop D3 and why would you prefer to
put the bishop here
and again case in point we get to put
this bishop on D3 and that is sort of
the most natural Square
but of course their opponent can do the
same because
our E5 Pawn is right there so Bishop B5
V Castle take
take Rook C8 Knight A3 takes takes A6
now I'm not gonna
pretend that this position is not
amazing for white it is pretty good
black probably underestimated the fact
that these two pawns are fairly far
behind to actually pose a real threat to
White's position and in general having
two pieces versus The Rook is favorable
with the sides who has the light pieces
in in this position
so row B1 Queen C7 Queen takes B5
now I said this and said this before and
I'm gonna say it again shirov is not
known to be the most solid player out
there so this next play by shirov is
going to be kind of entertaining and
also really really good
so you doing invite you all to try to
figure out what shirov played next
nice sacrifice
is that the only legal sacrifice
you could sacrifice your queen
I might be tongue-in-cheek just saying
so it's pretty important whenever you're
considering moves
don't just choose one try to think about
alternatives
and you may kind of surprise yourself
is also an option so we got this and we
got this and I didn't really say if
Knight B5 is bad didn't say it will be
five is bad it is something to compare
but for truly be able to compare it you
have to
kind of look at the options
why one would be preferable to the other
sacrifice
uh which one
why
are handic and check are in the under
square D6 yeah
bone he didn't do it yet but he did it
here
not bad but it did happen here
so the whole point is that if you take
icon ib5 and I just jump on in there and
just cause mad havoc on that side of the
board you go here check
and I just take everything I don't
necessarily even have to Checkmate you
because you are practically paralyzed
The Rook is going to fall
and compare the safety of those two
kings that one's pretty Breezy on d8 and
the one on G2 is just chilling Big Boy
time chilling on G2
so he decides to go Queen A3
you still need to follow up
hmm
Ruby seven very good
you're not fate
now what's really tricky about
sacrificing in chess is that
you're basically going all in if you
don't follow up correctly well it may
just sail away and it's gonna be a sad
sad time
where are you going
D3 Queen B1 we consider not H4 so what's
very important whenever you're kind of
strategizing and coming up with moves is
that your move has to have a purpose
once they don't have a purpose it's
basically just a waste of a tempo
in here a Tempo is kind of the
difference between a win and a loss
so how did you decide on Queen D3
instead of Queen B1
mm-hmm
okay so Queen D3 and what do you think
black is going to respond
okay book C4 will be
yeah queen queen like all these squares
are covered
again you see like I was talking about
that E5 phone being useful and it is
super useful no Queen D6
so indeed Queen D3 and actually here
black just gave up completely just
resigned said good game that's it don't
want anything more with this game if you
go here indeed as you said Rook b a
check and I take the queen
you can go here I take can go here I
take and even if you go here well
probably can just go here and just set
this up
or even Queen C2 but probably I would
prefer this one although maybe you could
threaten both if you go to C2
so quite a quick win right
so it's very possible to win quickly in
these positions if you have the proper
understanding but of course we have to
add the fact that black made a mistake
now this next game is going to be the
same line but with black actually
improving on the previous one
so it's the same variation same Advanced
line
same exact one take Stakes here but
instead of taking on B4
he goes Pawn to a five
and I know absolutely makes more sense
than the other one did
so let's try to figure it out let's try
to take a bit of our time to think how
should we respond to this one and of
course
I'm telling you how it is this is a
critical line if you want to pick up
shirov's secret weapon
then I mean I'm not going to surprise
you that Shiro found the best move here
leave five
okay
so how did you come up with the
conclusion of the B5 did you consider
anything else
okay
so if we go B5
why would this be superior to capturing
the pawn on A5
compare these two
it keeps the B fog closed yes
but it also just doesn't bring black
species alive right like black species
are going to get really really
aggressive
so B5 and in fact there's a pawn
Sacrifice by the way
because black can go check
and then they take the palm
so in fact yes we kind of play B5
because it looks natural but it also is
giving up a pawn
all right let's let's keep the spirit up
it's just the Palm it's just the pawn
you could try Knight C3
but in that case probably they just move
the queen
and they will get a lot of Pawns they're
gonna win this one
you have to move here which is a little
ugly
and black has full compensation so
shirov did not go for that one
even though it looks logical
castles
so I talk about this all the time but
it's true
only three things you need to do in
chess get the center get your pieces out
Castle
if you mess up this order you may
actually get into trouble for that
reason just that reason alone
Queen B6
now it is a bit of a turn we were being
a little bit haunted here because our
King was in the middle and sort of
attacked however our King moved away now
the hunter will get Hunted
so how can we
take that role
because now we can't do so
okay how will black respond
serve Knight C3
still probably black just takes
okay
yeah Bishop D3
just to activate your pieces so in
general like E2 is some standard way of
playing for most people and players but
the bishop is the most active on D3
because it often hits an important
Target there but let's continue here
even takes it wow greedy greedy Sheriff
taking the pawn on H7 now this would be
a dangerous uh proposition but here you
don't really have a way to block this
Pawn because it moved
from G7 to H6 so there's no G6 and F5 we
will teach them the rule of ampa song
and then we will still be up up one
so they go A4
so this is sort of like a tabiya so
typical position that you may get
I think Shiro's next move is somewhat
surprising but also makes a lot of sense
black is putting a ton of pressure on
the D4 Pawn
but actually Shiro finds a way to
release that pressure without really
moving any of these pawns it sounds
miraculous miraculous but it's actually
not
so we lose our Central Pawn I don't
think so or at least not now
it is pretty much defended
because it's the same amount of
Defenders three Defenders versus three
attackers
that's uh
that means that the pawn is guarded
so it looks kind of problematic because
I can't really move
because we lose the pawn
but we also have a piece that really
doesn't do anything anymore
that is really out there
and pretty pointless
it goes Bishop C2
and this will surprise you
now often that like you take the pawn
job is done you go back home you
couldn't really move your knight because
they would take the pawn there
Bishop C2 they hit the pawn
and oftentimes one of the ways you can
kind of ease the pressure
of the center Pawn is by setting up a
thread of your own so they will be busy
dealing with that so they go Queen A5
and now there is not as much of a
pressure on the D4 Pawn as a move ago
so this is actually a critical spot and
shirov comes up with a brilliant idea
just brilliant and it's more of a
strategic uh Choice than a single move
is there any critical squares in Black's
position that we love to control
hint hint
because there is
so if we use an Channel
our idea that we could put our knight
any of our Knight on a square which
Square would that be
F6
um
so
you need to have dreams
so you can achieve them
Knight E1 very very nice that's the
first step
Rook G7
Knight G2 what are we doing on G2
uh-huh
so we're going places actually we are
heading there
so quite an incredible maneuver
by share of by no means uh a decider but
it kind of starts to feel like it's
better for white
sound like this has to go B5 of course
we continue with Knight F4
Knight H5 takes
he takes on A3
he doesn't really take on G7 he says
well my knight is pretty strong why
would I give it up for a measly Rook
ready three takes takes here
so even though white is up material
that does not mean it will convert
itself
so we still have to look for new targets
and make sure we're Swift with our
attack this next move is again somewhat
surprising but again it's as inventive
as Shear of always is
Rook D3
it seems a little weird but you'll see
what he wants
uh-huh Rook F3
takes
so he doesn't necessarily care about the
Knight the Knight was as it kind of done
its job capturing The Rook he gives it
up and normally you wouldn't do this but
Shira realizes well this case I get a
very very aggressive Rook anytime you
get the tractor on the seventh it's
going to have maximum potential
you got two it's almost game over
Bishop h8
now that Rook alone as I said is
uncomfortable but it's not quite
decisive yet
so we may actually need to amp up the
pressure here
mm-hmm
very good
in G4 it also kind of stops the king
from coming there because that would
walk straight into the PIN
and also you're threatening to check and
go here
okay if they just go here
let's say we may just check there and
put pressure on The Rook
and the bishop of course
so it goes here
Rook H7
again that Bishop is mummified over
there because of the wall of the pawns
we have over on the E5 and D4
so it kind of shows that some openings
just deeply have a strategic element to
them this Advanced variation which is
shirov's pet and favorite secret weapon
does actually pose a lot of problems for
black if unawares
A2 green check Queen takes E6
Rook d8
so now we want to put an even bit more
pressure
on selects
Bishop F5 yeah Bishop F5 makes sense
I don't think he played that
he played Rook A1
uh Bishop F5 it probably go back but I
would presume your position is more or
less near winning
Rook A1
Knight takes D4
check King C8
Bishop D3 Knight B5
I should follow up
it's all about hunting the king nothing
else
just check just go on go after the king
Knight C7 takes
Bishop A6 check
very very brutal you can't touch this
because you're pinned
you can go here
because you are gonna get mated
yeah
so you go here takes
and you're just getting native even if
you promote that's just made in two
so here
takes
check and here resigns because Rook C7
is coming in and you get mated or you
lose all your pieces
so therefore sellag gave in
so I really hope you enjoyed this bit of
the advanced variation of the French
that is actually Alexis shirov's
favorite weapon but once again
if you want to see amazing games just
like this coming up shortly on Saturday
they're going to be a GCT a grand chess
Tour event at 7 00 a.m on Saturday it's
going to be an ongoing event so it's May
6th
so if you want to see some sparkling
chess
and if you want to play sparkling chess
yourself I wholeheartedly advise you to
try out Shiro's secret weapon thank you